salut c'est michael je suis à paris pour
la promo de mun avec toute l'équipe du
film alex benoît izia et omar lui c'est
mun
ce qu'il aime le plus c'est la liberté
mais une tu peux pas tenir tranquille le
film commence avec l'histoire de munich
un petit faune de la forêt que la lune
décide de sélectionner comme nouveau
gardien de l'année alors qu'il est pas
du tout habilité pour ça un événement va
changer son destin
voilà le nouveau gardien delà du dôme
une interprète mun gardien de la lune un
peu malgré lui c'est un petit peu
facétieux est assez timide un petit peu
réservé à ces fragiles
il va faire quelques bêtises il va
essayer de les réparer et puis
d'affronter f responsabilités quartier
de la lune je crois qu'il ya une méprise
mun va faire un pas mal de bêtises dont
décrocher la lune et le nez
l'opportunité aux méchants du film et
crossac de voler le soleil donc les deux
gardiens vont devoir s'allier pour
partir en quête du soleil et vont à
s'associer à sir pour partir dans cette
4l ccir avec son père tue la liberté
elle connaît pas elle mais dans mean
j'ai jou cyr je suis une jeune fille
anciens donc en fait si je m'approche
trop du soleil je fonce je m'approche
trop du froid de la lune juge elle du
coup je suis un peu entre deux tout le
temps et je dois un peu trouvé mon
équilibre h est aussi assez malicieuse
et intrépide et jamais ne sonne donc le
gardien du soleil joué par omar et mun
dans une aventure rocambolesque pour
essayer de récupérer la lune des
diablotins projet cela
c'était la première fois que j'ai doublé
c'était vraiment une envie forte quand
ils vont proposer j'ai pas trop cherché
à en savoir plus j'ai dû beaucoup tout
de suite et la journée d'enregistrement
a été vraiment une journée de plaisir et
de fun et c'est un exercice très très
très plaisant je veux réparer ce que
j'ai provoqué tout un jeu comme boulot
mini rongeurs je vous laisse continuer
votre concours d'ego on a eu plein les
désolé c'est un jeu de pouvoir incarner
interpréter des personnages comme celui
de mun qui fait des choses complètement
dingue
au quotidien on n'a pas l'occasion de
faire ça y a pas de formation pour être
gardien de la lune dans la vie quoi et
puis il ya ce qui est plaisant c'est
surtout de jouer le cinéma le doublage
c'est du jeu c'est des manières
différentes de jeu en ce qui me concerne
le le plaisir et les deux jouer et après
tout la technique moi je me focalise pas
trop dessus je me laisse guider là
dessus c'est le côté jeu qui mène dès le
début on a pensé comme un film en 3d
moi j'avais tout de suite envie de faire
un film qui soit novateur dans son style
graphique est hélas fort des talents qui
ont collaboré sur ce film n'a pu
installer ce look qui répond aussi à
toute la richesse du film parce que
c'est avec ce projet il est extrêmement
riche que ce soit dans tous ses
personnages dans tous ces environnements
coup les artistes s'en sont donné à
coeur joie multiplier leur palette
graphique et les textures sur le projet
quand je prends une matière de cinq
personnages c'est la première fois
qu'elle était si perceptible pour moi en
esthétique sais ce que c'est la première
chose que j'ai dit quand j'ai vu les
images du film
je sais exactement où on va un sac de
boue